im sommer nach corona geht es in der
bodestraße wieder los die frauen sitzen
in den fenstern die feier betrachten das
angebot viele frauen aus osteuropa sind
während des shutdowns in ihre
heimatländer zurückgekehrt
manche haben mir ausgeharrt immer in der
hoffnung bald geht es wieder los
ich will wissen wie läuft es jetzt und
wie bist du dann finanziell über die
runden gekommen wenn du jetzt nichts
verdient hast in den letzten wochen und
monaten ich habe mein erspartes fast
verbraucht das geld was du jetzt hier
verdienst kannst du auch behalten
natürlich ich arbeite für mich ich habe
niemanden der mir irgendwas abnimmt
kannst du auch sagen nee der ist mir
nicht sympathisch mit denen möchte ich
nicht aufs zimmer gehen ja deswegen bin
ich hier auf der laufstrecke wo ich den
man erst mal sehen kann wo ich eine
scheibe zwischen mir und ihm habe ich
sage dann ganz höflich tut mir leid ich
bin nicht die richtige für dich
für die einhaltung der auflagen und das
hygiene konzept sorgt die wirtschafterin
des modells die kunden sowie die mädels
oben am fenster müssen getestet geimpft
oder gewesen waren
das heißt wenn der mann hier kommt und
sagt die hübsche schwarzhaarige im
dritten fenster die gefällt mir dann
sagen sie zeige ich erstmal dahin
technologie und da müssen wir eine
kontaktliste ausfüllen also ein
kontaktformular wo draufsteht messen die
temperatur dann wird die temperatur
eingetragen
name anschrift name der dienstleisterin
ankunftszeit war da wieder raus geht und
die telefonnummer muss auch draufstehen
der ist aber der freiherr besteht nicht
begeistert oder lassen sie sich aus weiß
sein denn ja wie muss ja kontrollieren
ob das auch die person ist die jetzt den
impfpass oder den schnelltest vorzeichen
und kann das ja von jedem dieser frei
erzählt mir freimütig er sucht seine
und diese war heute nicht da das ist ja
mist
wir sind alle auch wirklich froh dass
man wieder selbstständig sein geld
verdienen kann
was würde der sind prostitutionsverbot
und ein sex verbot für sie bedeuten ein
prostitutionsverbot würde für mich
bedeuten dass ich in den untergrund
abtauchen müsste ich hätte dann
natürlich auch angst um einen schutz und
entdeckt zu werden
corona hat gezeigt was ein verbot
bedeuten würde
in baden württemberg sind die baustelle
geschlossen frauen tauchen ab in
appartements bieten wir bedingt dem
internet an
es ist märz dritte welle seit einem jahr
beobachte ich die situation von
prostituierten an sie heranzukommen
geben sich polizisten als freier aus
wollen herausfinden sind die frauen
offiziell angemeldet besteht verdacht
auf zwangsprostitution
ja hallo dass stefan hier ich habe da
eine anzeige im internet gesehen und
wollte fragen so wird abend noch einen
termin für mich 22 30
ja das wird passen super was soll ich
denn hier kommen zu kontrollieren aber
auch hilfe anzubieten ruhig für die
polizisten nicht einfach alles klar bis
später ist tatsächlich für die behörde
schwierig kontakt zu den frauen
aufzubauen die frauen zu kontrollieren
zeitaufwand eine kontrolle momentan
deutlich höher
also man muss erstmal im internet
recherchieren wie ein wille ständig
kontrollieren dann muss ich kontakt
aufnehmen termin vereinbaren ich muss
die örtlichkeit fahrende kontrolle
durchführen also die kontrolle einer
prostituierten dauert momentan etwa
stunde
betrieb gegangen habe in der gleiche
zeit 5 10 20
france telecom grüne hingegen bundesland
ist die situation anders kommt
den merkwürdigkeiten in corona shutdown
dass in baden württemberg haben modelle
geschlossen sind und hat die tour aber
erlaubt ist auch den straßenstrich
dürfen wir die beamten gleich in die
neigungen wegen der infektionsgefahr
nicht okay 15 jahre habe ich mal 15
jahre zusammen aber manchmal auch hier
und was macht ein mann hier arbeit auch
mir kontrollierten die polizisten ob die
frauen angemeldet sind wollen aber auch
zeigen dass ansprechpartner sind wenn
die frauen in not geraten weil hier eine
kollegin kommen sagt ihr dürft nicht
arbeiten stimmt nicht ihr könnt mich
anrufen
arbeitet ihr für euch oder habt ihr ein
mann der jetzt sagt er mit dem geld nun
führungsduo arbeit ist nur für dich er
ja du auch mehr
gewinner wäre alles in ungarn auto und
wohnung und alles geht er zurück ja auch
für erfahrene polizisten ist es oft
nicht leicht hinter die kulissen zu
schauen
der übergang zwischen lebensgefährte
[Musik]
freund im zuhälter ist natürlich
fließend und es gibt auch viele frauen
die sage ja der mann fährt mich da passt
auf mich auf der holt mir zigaretten
kaffee und dafür bekommen der pro nacht
20 euro hat geschäftsbeziehungen
das sind die übergänge wirklich fließen
so sehr schwer von außen zu beurteilen
wo fällt zuhälterei an wo fängt die
ausbeutung an wenn die frau und sage nur
wer angemeldet ist dafür stehen die
frauen oft aus dem fernbus direkt in den
kopf viele prostituierte gerieten durch
bewohner im mut
maria wollte nicht auf den straßen
diese unterstützung bauen kann
[Musik]
kleine hilfe für notunterkünfte
ausstiegsangebote
ich habe keine wohnung keine gehe
ok ich brauche hilfe
möchtest du eine andere arbeit machen
wir haben eine reinigungsfirma mit der
wir zusammenarbeiten
da ist auch eine möglichkeit ja leider
in meinen job ich kann verdient mehr
games andré platz erreichen
sie ernährt ihre familien im heimatland
aber sicherheit ist ihr wichtig und die
sagt gibt es kommt also du möchtest mich
irgendwo in einem zimmer ganz alleine
sitzen ohne sicherheitslücken allein
erfolg kommen
von unten cellulite und hilft ja das ist
natürlich schade so gut hier hat sie
vorher gearbeitet der betreiber mit sein
buch komplett renoviert als 2000 sich
die das prostituierten schutzgesetz im 8
ball
es soll frauen vor gewalt und
menschenhandel schönste betreiber bekam
auflagen
sie vermied und dem frauenzimmer
aber keine anweisungen gegen die frauen
sollen selbst bestimmen was sie anbieten
wir haben auch nach dem neuen fonds
schutz gesetzt alles umgesetzt was
verlangt worden ist zum beispiel haben
wir hier ein alarmknopf bei probleme und
schwierigkeiten den damen können sie
drücken da kommen sicherheitsdienst hoch
ja wir haben dem schrank am safe wurde
ihre privatsache einschließen können
und jetzt jetzt ist hier alles leer und
wo sich die frauen ja die frauen
arbeiten privat leider ohne schutz und
unsere häuser wo eigentlich alles das
geben was der gesetzgeber verlangt
stelle auch schon hier hat sein bordell
konzert im amt überprüfen lassen hat
eine konzession bekommen
angemeldete brauchen der gesetzgeber
habe ihn als unternehmer anerkannten der
nicht obst und gemüse sondern sexuelle
dienstleistungen verkaufen auch
bordellbetreiber bekamen corona hilfen
die kritik daran ärgert ihn
ausgestattet mit dem was das
prostituierten schutzgesetz fordert auch
hier dass ein notfall knöpfe saves
duschen rasch träume wir sind keine
kriminellen denn des prostituierten
schutzgesetz auch das ist ein vortrag
vom gesetz sagt ganz klar aus und es
wird auch so umgesetzt dass nicht nur
der betreiber sondern auch die
mitarbeiter geprüft werden wir müssen
ein großes führungszeugnis bringen wir
dürfen keine vorstrafen haben ansonsten
kriegen wir weder die konzession noch
darf der mitarbeiter bei uns arbeiten
wenn ein mitarbeiter beispielsweise
vorbestraft ist wegen körperverletzung
darf er nicht mehr arbeiten wenn die
prostituierte hier morgens raus wandert
können sie sicherstellen dass nicht
enthüllt hier um die ecke steht und sagt
loos her mit den kröten ob es bei der
polizei oder einem gesundheitsamt ist
wird ein anderthalbstündiges gespräch
geführt in dem herausfiel triert werden
soll und herausgefunden werden soll ob
die frau unter zwang arbeitet und nicht
ob sie weiß in welchem land sie ist und
wird dort aufgeklärt
erst dann bekommt sie hatte
bescheinigung des für uns zumindest mal
die erste sicherheit dessen ist das
vorwissen moment einmal
zwangsprostitution in der form her ist
immer kundgetan hat findet nicht statt
die hundertprozentige absicherung in
jedem bereich ist nicht möglich das
prostituierten schutzgesetz verpflichtet
jede prostituierte sich beim gesundheits
und ordnungsamt anzumelden
im gespräch sollen die mitarbeiter
herausfinden ob sie freiwillig
landschaft betrüger unter zwang
klappt das kann bei einem erstgespräch
wirklich die zwangslage einer frau
abgeklärt werden
wann läuten bei ihnen die alarmglocken
wo sie sagen irgendwas stimmt hier nicht
wenn jemand frisch mit 18 über die
grenze gebracht wird
oder kommt ja dann frage ich natürlich
mich schon wie kann es dann sein wenn
jemand sehr unsicher wird wenn ich angst
spüre und da vertraue ich sehr auf mein
bauchgefühl
haben sie da in den letzten drei bis
vier jahren mal so einen fall gehabt da
von menschenhandel oder
zwangsprostitution denn das war ja der
anspruch eigentlich des gesetzes genau
dieses zu verhindern gewalt zwang also
es gab einen fall wo auch die frau dann
zwei wochen nach meiner beratung die
polizei bei der arbeit angesprochen und
gesagt hat nimmt mich jetzt damit dass
prostituierten schutzgesetz mit all
seinen auflagen genügt einigen
bundestagsabgeordneten nicht durch den
corona shutdown fühlte sich besteht
in ihrer forderung sex kauf ganz zu
verbieten und freier zu bestrafen
ähnlich wie in einigen ländern
nordeuropas prostitution gibt es seit
2000 jahren ist das nicht eine illusion
zu meinen das könnte man tatsächlich
verbieten
doch man kann es versuchen man geht
nicht und kaufte sich eine frau die
jungen männer die in deutschland die
letzten 20 jahre aufgewachsen sind die
haben gelernt es ist normal in ein
bordell zu gehen und sich eine frau zu
kaufen und für wenig geld mit einer frau
zu machen was man will und deshalb
glaube ich nicht dass es damit getan ist
hier ein paragrafen zu ändern und dort
was zu ändern und deshalb sage ich wir
brauchen einen text käufer bot doch
gezeigt was dann passiert dieses modell
in berlin ist geschlossen die zimmer
leer
doch antonia braucht geld und besuchten
feier zu hause da führt auch irgendwie
auch das gefühl von sicherheit was man
hier in dem bordell hat beim normalen
nämlich 150 euro für eine stunde und sie
wollen das halt wirklich immer weiter
runter drücken auf mit dem gummi zu
schlafen und das wird einfach schamlos
ausgenutzt was würde das für dich
bedeuten jetzt wenn sex verboten wird
das wäre also dass der vorteil dass wir
auf jeden fall wer wird also wäre
schlecht für mich doch es gibt frauen
die alles was sie verdienen abgeben
müssen als junges mädchen wurde sandra
nora opfer eines 20 jahre älteren lover
boy schaffte fühlt
jahrelang an das war vor einführung des
prostituiertengesetzes aber es ist
überzeugt das gesetz habe an der lage
der frauen nichts geändert
alle frauen die ich kennengelernt habe
haben gesagt sie machen das freiwillig
ich hab auch sogar ist die polizei mich
damals aufgesucht habe habe ich gesagt
ich mache das alles nur für mich viele
leute stellen sich menschenhandel und
zwangsprostitution vor frauen in ketten
ja die irgendwo im keller sitzen und die
wenn sie polizei sehen würden
schreien würden hier ich bin opfer von
menschenhandel aber so sieht es in der
realität nicht aus wenn sie wenn sie in
dem bordell gehen ja und sie sehen dort
die frauen ja die werden sie an lächeln
ja die werden mit ihnen scherze machen
die werden sagen sie machen das für sich
selbst ja aber hintenrum läuft ein ganz
anderes spiel ab und so funktioniert s
milieu so funktioniert das rotlicht ich
meine wir reden von einem geschäft wo
milliarden mit der ausbeutung von
menschen meist frauen gemacht wird die
loverboy masche funktioniert immer noch
drei monate schaffte jasmin für ein mann
an der emi bevor spielte und so benutzt
und der stand unter dem druck eines
menschen händlers leben wird von der
frauenorganisation cobra unterstützt ihr
prozess bericht die wirklich sobald du
merkst wirken der aussage dass es ihr
nicht gut geht ausdruck pause benötigst
zeichen dem richter seiner anwältin und
ich gebe dir dann sofort heraus wie bist
du in dieser situation überhaupt ein
geraten dass du als prostituierte
arbeiten musstest
er hat ein inserat irgendwie erstellt
aufkauf mg.de wir wurden zu
verschiedenen männern geschickt im
bordell weil ich auch mal aber ansonsten
lief das alles nur privaten wohnungen
also von ganz jungen bis ganz alt war
alles dabei
aber mir blieb keine andere wahl als ja
zu sagen und damit hin zu fahren weil
ich die ganze zeit unter druck gesetzt
worden bin und quasi dazu gezwungen
worden wenn das zu machen wie viel geld
hast du ihm in dieser zeit eingebracht
um die 92.000 euro und im bordell ist da
jemals eine kontrolle gekommen vom
ordnungsamt oder von der polizei
die marke satan bist du angemeldet du
bist ja so jung
also es kam weder an eine kontrolle noch
kam die polizei mal ins bordell oder so
es war nie der fall gewesen
so kommt es nur zu wenigen verfahren vor
gericht in landgericht frankfurt wies
heute um zuhälterei gewalt und
menschenhandel
doch ohne die bereitschaft der frau
auszusagen platzen solche prozesse
oft üben täter im heimatland druck aus
zieh deine aussage zurück wir wissen gut
eine kindertisch
so kommen die täter davon
2009 10 gab es nur 287 verfahren wegen
menschenhandels in einem rechtsstaat
gilt die unschuldsvermutung wenn das
opfer nicht aus sagt der strafrichter
verurteilte nach strafgesetzen diese
strafgesetze müssen erfüllt sein
und sie sind erfüllt durch bestimmte
angaben die zum beispiel ein opfer macht
und sagt das sind das ist mir
widerfahren und der richter sagt okay
das erfüllt den straftatbestand der
zuhälterei oder des menschenhandels
aber wenn solche andere haben nicht da
sind kann darf ein richter nicht
verurteilen und ich habe es auch schon
erlebt in einem verfahren dass eine frau
sich dann geweigert hat auszusagen
aus angst lauter angst ja an sie können
noch davon ausgehen dass die meisten
delikte gar nicht an die öffentlichkeit
kommen und insbesondere nicht so an
gerichtsverfahren führen also da ist die
dunkelziffer mit sicherheit sehr sehr
hoch um opfer von menschenhandel und
zwangsprostitution zu schützen müsste
man das strafrecht ändern
dazu teilt mir das
bundesjustizministerium mit eine
änderung der strafprozessordnung
das opfer von menschenhandel in einem
strafverfahren nicht persönlich
vernommen werden müssen ist nicht
beabsichtigt eine schwachstelle bei der
verfolgung von menschen hinter doch ist
einziges kaufverbot eine lösung
corona de zeigt die frauen würden ab
doch während für hilfen schwerer
erreichbar menschen im verhältnis noch
leicht
corona und aufgezeigt es gibt
anlaufstellen für frauen in not aber
viel zu wenig schutz im heimat landen
damit sie sich trauen menschenhändler an
zutaten
es fehlt auch ein bessere abstimmung
zwischen den ämtern an der ausbildung
der mitarbeiter im juni wurde das
prostituierten schutzgesetz verschärft
freier werden bestraft wenn sie die
zwangslage einer frau
aus mindestens 20 millionen euro soll es
für ausstiegsangebote zb alternative
jobs geht aber allen jobcentern
frauen die ganze familien ernähren
gespielt das prostituierten schutzgesetz
gut gemeint aber nicht gut gemacht
[Musik]